so so i want to we're going to jump to
this next story and i hate to do this
because it's just it's kind of if you
hate to do it you don't have to we won't
make it
i think we do and uh so so we have the
story from digital music news they say
spotify employees threaten to strike
if joe rogan podcasts aren't edited or
removed
what so there's been an ongoing thing
with the rogan podcast which to which to
joe is probably
more of a like mosquito on his arm that
he swats away and ignores
but has been relevant to those who are
active
in uh cultural politics and the digital
space so particularly
you know a space that like i'm in i hate
i hate to constantly be bringing up joe
because they're the ones bringing him up
i love
this kind of joe man it's it's it's it's
a little tabloidy because the co
the the first thing i want to say is you
know bring on the criticism i get it
you know talking about joe all the time
he is the biggest podcast in the world
with like the biggest podcast deal ever
he's the og and now in the culture war
comes for him
to to you know repeatedly in these
stories
i think it is particularly relevant
because it's going to trickle down on
everybody else
dude what is going on with these
podcasts and what we need to pay
attention to
so as much as i i want to be like we get
it spotify employees repeatedly are
pushing these stories try and come after
joe this one to me was like
another example of uh the danger
of the minority threatening to destroy
things that are extremely popular
and potentially even having an impact so
uh i don't know
if if you know to work sent you've heard
this i think you knew about the scene
that a bunch of episodes didn't make it
oh onto spotify yeah whose episodes that
they refused to tell us jones gavin
mcinnes
carl benjamin and a joke a statement
that it was uh
a clerical error oh that's insane also i
mean i don't know
i guess i'll just give joe the benefit
of the doubt but on top of that too
carl benjamin sargon is so much less
controversial than any of the other
names you threw out there and i'm not
saying those podcasts should have been
banned either but it's just
it's funny carl has his moments that's
fair when i was
when i was on rogan's show with the
twitter people and they were talking
about why they banned him and started
reading some of the things
he said oh carl actually messaged me and
he was like
he was laughing and he was like you're
probably saying like oh carl what have
you
done yeah okay fair enough i'm not
familiar with his twitter
but it's crazy to me that they would
they would refuse to allow him to upload
streams he did with
any of those people but especially i
don't know i always just saw sargon to
be a lot less controversial
maybe i don't follow him closely enough
did spotify nuke those episodes
or did was there a clerical error i
thought i read that joe said that it was
an error that they didn't get uploaded
properly so why why
why would why why would that pattern
seem to no it seems like a pattern
why would alex alex jones episode one of
the biggest episodes had like 15 million
views in a day
you know i'm not i i don't think joe's a
liar yeah exactly so i mean and i can't
confirm the statement
but hold on it it could be legit
it could be that those are the ones
youtube corrupted
that's possible they get more
conspiratorial maybe yeah i have no idea
i'm interested in what his contract was
with spot i would have imagined
when he signed with them he was like i
have total freedom you're not going to
touch any of my stuff and everything's
going up
you win okay let's go and i can't
imagine he would do anything but that i
don't know joe rogan as a person i've
never spoken to him but based on who he
is on the podcast
it would shock me if there wasn't
something in the contract to ensure that
he had full creative freedom there's
tricks
there's a lot of tricks let me let me
read this for so so we'll see what it's
all about and then
we'll talk about it so digital music
news reports a contingent of activists
spotify staffers are now considering a
walkout or full-blown strike
if their demands for direct editorial
oversight of the joe rogan experience
podcasts aren't met
last week we first reported spotify
employees were demanding direct
editorial oversight over the recently
acquired joe rogan experience podcast
that would include the ability to
directly edit or remove sections of
upcoming interviews
or block the uploading of episodes
deemed problematic
the employees also demanded the ability
to add trigger warnings corrections and
references to fact check articles
on topics discussed by rogan in the
course of his multi-hour discussions
some of the group's demands have already
been met by spotify management
though a refusal to allow further
changes is stirring talk
of a high-profile walkout or strike
according to preliminary plans shared
with digital music news
the strike would principally involve new
york-based spotify employees
and would be accompanied by protests
outside spotify's manhattan headquarters
other aspects would involve media
appearances and coordination with other
activist organizations
for spotify the decision to offer some
concessions may have only emboldened
demands
for wide scale editorial oversight
during the transition of rogan's podcast
episodes under the spotify platform
multiple past episodes were omitted
those included interviews with miley
annopolis gavin mcinnis and alex jones
additionally rogan issued a rare public
apology and correction
over his claim that left-wing anarchists
had set fires in oregon
a point that was made during a recent
interview with douglas murray the
apology is now believed to be the result
of pressure from spotify staffers
but those measures apparently don't go
far enough rogan's claim during the
murray podcast is still part of the
podcast recording
despite demands that the offending
section will be removed or directly
corrected within the audio itself
it now appears that spotify is unwilling
to directly edit or otherwise
otherwise alter any existing episodes
with content alteration considered a
bright line
that shouldn't be crossed the joe that
episode
on uh facebook right now is flagged as
fake news
wow all right so if you if you link the
youtube video a thing appears saying
false information
and it's a whole podcast so from that
one
thing joe said i would wouldn't mind if
he put a little
cut in there and added like hey guys by
the way what i'm about to say is really
ignorant
here it is no this is the reason it's
ignorant that's insane
even though how many of you have
anything how many wrong things have we
said in this podcast how many wrong
things have we said right every time i
opened
that we would have to go back and look
at it when i'm not yeah like if i can
even get a sentence out it's usually
incorrect
so everybody would have me listen listen
no in all seriousness i i hear what
you're saying
what you said though i think that would
be fine for joe to do if he wanted to
if he wants to because i've done that
too right like i've uploaded videos
and then noticed that there was a little
error with it and then taking it down
redone it or just cut that part out and
then re-uploaded it
because sometimes i feel that there's a
responsibility to do that edit it while
it's online without
having to take it down you can't do that
youtube can do that you can do that on
youtube now yes how long have you been
able to do that for
long time because i'm an i okay i'm an
idiot i totally pulled something down
and sliced it out and i probably get
i tried to look for that feature though
i didn't find it it's called it's called
split you go in and you go split and you
go nope you can you can trim the edges
and you can pull things out
it takes a really long time to do like
it could take like two days for it to
finally process
interesting you're doing it through the
cloud and whatever i remember attempting
to do it but there were some weird
issues it was like
the cut had to be much longer than the
one that i wanted to make but this
that's neither here nor there i got to
read this because it's funny
digital music news says if a walk-out
strut or strike moves forward it could
be risky for the staffers involved
other corporations have certainly
witnessed walkouts and even full-blown
strikes by activist employees for a
range of grievances
those protests have often been met with
changes though
uh though the employment landscape has
changed dramatically in 2020
spotify employees reportedly enjoy
comfortable salaries in the 120-130
000 annual range with considerable perks
and benefits
these are plum these are plum jobs in
extremely uncertain economic times
making a strike a risky move it also
appears that spotify management
including ceo daniel eck has a limited
tolerance for the mutiny on deck
accordingly digital music news has
learned that spotify clearly shared its
decision
on the schreier episode and has declined
continued demands to edit or remove
other episodes so that's abigail
schreier she's
she wrote a book about transgender youth
and i think something that's called
i believe it's called rapid onset gender
dysphoria correct yeah she wrote this
book called irreparable damage how the
transgender
thing is uh ruining our daughter's lives
and and
joe was one of the few people who
actually was willing like i mean
i'm surprised to even did the interview
to be honest it was a good interview
good for him and it goes against the
the mainstream orthodoxy and that's why
they're freaking out they say the reason
x pushback is somewhat obvious
joe rogan's entire identity revolves
around unfiltered discussion and opinion
and audiences could abandon the podcast
if it becomes censored or controlled
earlier this year spotify lured rogan
into an exclusive relationship with an
estimated 100 million dollar deal
so if you're an employee who makes 100k
and you go and say i'm gonna strike
unless we get to you know make these
changes
yeah what do you think that guy's gonna
say hmm should i lose a
one employee or a hundred million dollar
contract exactly buddy the door is right
behind you dude that's exactly what i
was but
hold on hold on here's where it gets fun
what if the employees now claim
being in a work environment where they
hear sexist racist and transphobic
content is a violation of their
civil night civil rights under the civil
rights act they say it's discrimination
for me to have to work on content that
says these things
that's been the big advantage that's
been the big manipulation the left has
used
arguing that their political cause is
actually protected so the new york times
did
is they started tweeting out all of when
uh it was it was it was tom cotton right
tom cotton uh sending the troops article
yeah tom cotton wrote an article on
op-ed
send in the troops called for the
insurrection act to shut down the riots
so new york times employees started
tweeting
the new york times is endangering black
bodies or something to that effect
where did that phrase come from they
start saying black bodies instead of
black people i've heard this
i think i think it's a reference to that
they are white supremacists who don't
view them as human beings just like
animate corpses walking around a blast
so then why are you saying it though you
know what i mean like why are you no no
i'm saying right now
i know no no no no no i know i know why
you're saying i'm saying like why
because i've seen left-wing people use
this phrase like
if they think that that represents white
supremacists not seeing black people
assuming like then why are they using
this term
no no no no no no i was i was being
facetious i know you were i know you
were they don't actually believe saying
black body is a reference to white
supremacy
no i've seen this oh oh why do they say
it then i don't have no idea it's a
social justice league
i was dragging them okay okay i was i
thought that i was calling for them
right that's my bad that's my best but
listen i don't i don't know what a black
body is i don't know it's a scientific
thing that absorbs all light
sure sure i don't want to derail off of
what's going on with the new york times
they used the idea that the new york
times was discriminating against black
people
as a way to force the company to take
down the op-ed
and ultimately the editor resigned they
are using civil rights law
and they are claiming well if there is
content that i have to listen to
because i work at this company that is
that is discriminatory against me and my
beliefs and who i am
and how the supreme court has ruled that
you can't discriminate against someone
on the basis of
uh their their gender identity that was
the supreme court ruling you remember
that was a month or so ago
yeah we were actually discussing that
and you made a really good point about
the fact that
we don't actually have to change
legislation as long as the language
changes
so when they change definitions yeah
exactly well so the supreme court ruled
that if you can't discriminate on the
basis of sex gender identity and
orientation
are rooted in your biological sex
therefore
they're protected as well so now here's
what might happen or
i don't i don't say might the spotify
employees
just like the new york times employees
they're doing the same thing
so maybe we'll see i would say if you're
looking for a job apply at spotify right
now
yeah that's funny i mean i hear what
you're saying it drives me crazy though
because this is something that happens
in the creative world so often and i
have not worked anywhere near the
mainstream
creative world but i have a number of
friends who have and whenever you work
on a property that's been acquired
there's always this tension between the
people who have acquired the property
and the people who originally created it
because no one can ever buy something
and then just let the creator do it the
way that they were originally doing it
no one can ever see that something is
successful and say this guy knows what
he's doing i'm going to let him run the
show because he was doing it fine before
i came along
it would be smart for me to just let him
continue and take a little piece of this
so i can enrich myself
no it's so prideful
and ridiculous and they screw themselves
because they end up making less money in
the long run when they ruin it
yes a lot of times but it's about
fitting that into
so they have a jigsaw puzzle and they
take this piece
and they start carving it to fit the
mold and they remove the good
things before when i was a stupid kid
forcing jigsaw yeah like i cut it into
the right place because i couldn't find
the right
piece so some of the things i've asked
you know in relation to what's going on
the rogan podcast is
uh the first thing i'll point out is the
inherent political danger of joe rogan's
apology
in that media matters for america
attacks joe saying he's putting out
dangerous misinformation because joe
insinuated leftists were starting fires
joe says something
the left is doing x the left responds by
saying you're a liar joe responds by
saying
sorry that wasn't true but part of it
was true
so now joe's put out misinformation and
when other people point that out there's
no apology
you see that you see what i mean there's
no correcting the record so what happens
is
the it's once again falling back on
playing the left's game
when they're not playing the same rules
they will demand an apology from you
you'll get it they will never apologize
for for what they're doing
when the right says the left should
apologize for this remember when like
we had the dude with the he posted a
picture of the guy throwing
throwing the covington kids in a wood
chipper oh yeah who was that
that whole thing that whole thing they
refuse the media companies refuse to
apologize
they settle you know some undisclosed
number they won't
give you anything at all so why
is anyone giving them anything in return
yeah why i don't
i don't understand why it is that joe
would apologize for this
but then not apologize for anything else
he's ever said has been incorrect
so this comes back to playing their game
we are choosing to play by their rules
and i really hope that joe does not
decide to go through with this and and
kowtow or anything like that i hope that
he
sticks to his guns and stays strong
because he is just
he's a very nice guy he's very common
sense he doesn't really mean he does not
mean anyone any harm i know
for sure have you can watch hours but
he's done it
what do you mean he did apologize
already oh yeah and the apology was
incorrect
i know i feel like i'm kind of beating a
dead horse i've talked about it so many
times but it's in
you know just in the context of they're
continually putting pressure on him to
try and get him to make concessions
but i think that is a separate issue
because this the the
whole idea of editing or removing his
podcasts
is just completely insane and i hope
that he doesn't count
out to that i hope that he's not about
what he wants me to it doesn't it
doesn't matter what what he says it's
what people don't understand
they're saying uh uh i think it was
james lindsay who tweeted
if they think they're gonna get away
with this they don't know who joe rogan
is
and it's like perhaps if you trust that
he did a good job with his legal
contract
his case contract in terms of the
licensing deal with spotify for sure
but if it's just a licensing licensing
deal then spotify under any obligation
to actually post any of those podcasts
um i don't know man i would i would have
to see the contract it's pretty
pretty i don't i i would be surprised
based on the contracts i've dealt with
if there was a provision saying
if i make the content you must publish
it
no every license every licensing deal
silence
that's called golden handcuffs horrific
it's called golden handcuffs they do it
all
the time that's why i'm like i wouldn't
be surprised if joe actually knew
and and didn't fall into these traps but
every licensing deal i've seen
doesn't have an obligation for licensing
they say we're going to license your
content
here's how much we'll pay you say okay
that's freaky that's normal
and so i'd imagine with an exclusive
contract it
to me i i you know look he's the biggest
podcast in the world i'm sure they went
through all these contracts with a
fine-tooth comb and and like they're
probably some of the craziest contracts
in the world
but the deals that i've negotiated where
i've demanded guarantees
have just collapsed when i say no no i
want to guarantee that you're actually
going to be working on this and they say
well we can't guarantee that because
have a nice day no i hear you i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna give away my content
and then have it just disappear into a
dark corner in exchange for money i
don't care i like the content more than
i care about the money
yeah good for you you give you give me a
can you give me a cell phone and i'll
sit in the middle of the woods and just
blabble on for a million years
i can live in a hut and or go down by
the river and just go fishing in my own
business
but there are a lot of people fall into
these traps
i've had a bunch of contracts offered to
me over the past couple of years that
have been
laughable there's like a really big
podcasting network that sent me a
contract that basically said
in very sneaky terms i would give them
100
ownership of all of my all of my
platform and content and everything and
then they make you feel like they're
doing
that you're wrong exactly that they're
doing you a favor too and when i
responded with
i i read it i said please send me the
real contract
and they said this is the normal boiler
blah blah blah and i said
if you i said no this contract signs
over the ownership of my business
which i will not do if you like to talk
about a purchase it's different from a
licensing agreement
and they said it's normal this is what
lawyers are for
and my response was essentially a few
words longer than fu
if you think i'm gonna drop thousands of
dollars on a lawyer because you're
trying to rip me off yeah you can go
have a nice day i don't care like i said
i'll go down in the woods and film
myself on an iphone be like i don't i
don't need this i don't need you
i'm not going to deal with this but
these these pitfalls exist and they're
all over the place and i have seen some
really really clever ones what they
could do things in a contract where they
say something like
this following provision only applies to
a c grade manager
you know of a company and will not
pertain specifically to high ranking
officials x y and z
and then say content produced by these
people will be property of this company
then you go seven pages down and it'll
say for all intents and purposes
a c level manager could include this
that and this c section 7b
you go seven pages away and then guess
what you are a c-level manager you see
how they do it
they they can say don't worry we're not
taking your stuff it just says we're
taking sea level manager stuff
like employees because they work for us
right then 10 pages later you find out
that means you
those are the tricks they do yeah i mean
it's so evil but it's hilarious because
the entire purpose of a contract is so
you can have some clear agreement on
paper that both parties have consented
to but
obviously once lawyers get involved
everyone's just trying to screw the
other person over not all the time but
they make it much easier for you to do
that if you have all the tricky legal
language at your disposal
i won't sign anything i don't know i
always say give me one sheet of paper
that explains what it is yes
exactly that one has to be one she and
they're like there's no way i'm like i
don't care
yeah like i i've done uh like
sponsorship things where it's like they
give me this like 10 page thing
and i was like you want me to shout you
out and you want me to sign that and
they're like don't worry it's no
no it doesn't have a nice day bye bye
i'm not doing it what do they say do
they insist that you sign it
and go away or do they do they go like
oh well if you're not going to sign it
we'll just do the sponsorship anyway or
we'll get well
i'll tell you what a lot of the times
i'm a bit too short with a lot of people
you make it clear that there's no
relationship there
i straight up say if you come to me
and try to screw me yeah i will kick you
out the door
without without a moment's notice
there's no second chance
you bring me a contract and you give me
bunk bs
i'm gonna look at it i'm gonna say get
out of my building now and never come
back you're out
and and i'll tell you this i often
advise people there's no such thing as
no in business only terms
so if someone comes to you and they give
you bad terms you don't say no you say
improve the terms at a certain point
however i'm sick and tired of them
constantly flinging
garbage at me assuming i'm too stupid to
realize how to run a business
yeah these people think they can get
away with it look at what kanye west was
tweeting about i don't know if you saw
this stuff where he talks about the
labels ripping people off
that's what it is especially with young
people they probably assume like you
know a lot of these contracts in the
past few years i'm like
in my late 20s i'm in my early 30s and
they're like we're going to take
everything you and i'm like you think
i'm a [ __ ] don't you
you think you can come up to someone
who's like you know late 20s early 30s
and they're not smart enough they
haven't had enough experience
you waste my time and you waste my money
i will not do business with you
people do make those deals though that's
the sad thing that's why they keep
trying they know that they have success
in that
exactly the reason why you just say no
and stop negotiating is enough time like
once you get to a certain exactly
exactly negotiation's expensive so the
way i have to explain to people is uh
i'll ask you this because i don't think
i've ever asked you this before
if your phone rang right now i was
sitting here and it was mcdonald's
and you were like what is this and they
said sheamus we want you
to be a cashier at the mcdonald's
location
in washington you know central dc you
know yes no conditions
yes do it yeah but what would you really
say like you've got a call right now for
mcdonald's and said you
want to be a cashier i'd say god bless
you um
but i have other things that i'm
invested in right now that i find more
rewarding than that position would
probably be for me at this point in time
so for so to be fair for you that's
probably you have your own business you
have a successful channel
the what i tell people when they're
trying to get started in life and
they're trying to find jobs the correct
answer
is most people say no like most people i
know of college degrees they're like i
would not no i'd say no of course
it's the wrong answer the correct answer
is how much money exactly yeah that's
what i figured
and so then then they always respond
with oh
but they're not gonna pay me so who
cares then you don't take a job you
didn't want in the first place
yeah so if they if they call you and say
we want you to be a cashier you say
i want 50 bucks an hour and when they
say we do not pay that much well thank
you for your time you have a nice day
end of story i mean because mcdonald's
is calling me right
i've got i've got all the power here
well he reached out to me that's a good
point
could ask for more money i figured i
couldn't negotiate for a little more
like i love what i'm doing you really
want me to be a cashier
you know it we just need that smile this
is so increased sales spotify bought
joe rogan to put gold handcuffs on him
mcdonald's wants to put gold handcuffs
on me by making that you got to read the
comments
i don't think they both put gold in
handcuffs no i'm i'm being facetious i
have no idea what that situation is i
love joe man
and yeah he's awesome he's so important
i think so
it's worrying then when you see stories
like this and and here's here's why i'm
like
i was begrudgingly saying like i don't
really want to talk about it because it
feels very tabloidy
yeah yeah talking about people does kind
of for sure especially like because i've
talked about him now i think four times
and referenced a lot of the same things
but the issue is that he's at the top of
the pyramid when it comes to podcasting
right and what happens to his his show
is going to in fact politics culture and
the podcasting world so you see the
people listening
the work we do there's actually like
precedent for them to be like
this is of upsetting my rights because i
have to see
offensive stuff that's gross vice vice
had something called a non-traditional
workplace agreement that you'd assign
when you got hired there
this was an agreement that said you
recognize that you know i design it
in this workplace you will encounter
content like this like that whatever and
you acknowledge you will not
take issue as a media company we do
these things and vice was
basically forced to remove that because
leftist activists
started claiming it was used to allow
the man at the company to sexually
assault women
which is ridiculous so when all these
stories of like assault started coming
out from the higher ranking vice people
then all of a sudden we started hearing
these stories did you know they have a
non-traditional workplace agreement that
says these things and it got leaked
online and everybody read it
vice had people sign that to prevent
them from saying
i walked into the workplace and saw you
know a porn video playing
yeah it's like well you work for a
magazine and this is a part of the job
you're
like these are the kind of content you
engage with sometimes you're gonna hear
like when vice goes to
uh the middle east and you hear someone
yelling like racial and ethnic slurs
about
their rival tribe or country people
would get triggered or angry by
it or what about when vice went
interviewed klansmen
and they started saying a whole bunch of
racist things so people are going to say
the fact they make me have to edit this
when it was derogatory about me i
believe is a violation of my righteous
discrimination
wow so so that so i don't know exactly
what would happen
in that capacity but that is why you end
up with non-traditional workplace
agreements
yeah we had something similar at mines i
mean i think i had to actually
write that in to the my own job because
i would witness i was like an admin at
mines and i would see like the boost
console coming through and it was just
terrifying some visceral like the christ
church shooting i saw so many
20 times of like in the the doom it was
like with the video game overlay like a
first person shooter
gunning women in the head and like wow
that's just horrible
you know it changed me and and and i had
to deal but i just
quit the job i'm not going to like well
that's that's traumatic
yeah that's traumatic that's not hearing
a discussion about whether or not
children should be given hormones i
couldn't tell the
the platform to not host it it's it's
not the platform is a is a platform it's
not a publisher is spotify a publisher
or platform they're a publisher
well that's different yeah you have to
you have to get permission to pro
to post so look i'm not saying i know
for sure that will happen
but i throw it back to things like the
non-traditional workplace argument
advice and how
the new york times employees accused new
york times of being racist
for allowing an article about riots that
are predominantly white
what so so what happened yes yes so
white people are rioting
so tom cotton says send in the military
and stop the riots so the new york times
employee says
that's racist and the new york times is
is endangering black bodies or something
like that oh my god
that's what their claim they and then it
worked the editor from the opinion page
had to resign
they actually pulled the article and the
guy resigned i don't know if they pulled
it but they put a whole bunch of like
apologies and explanations and we're
trying to desperately be like oh please
don't cancel your subscription
yeah spineless you know what i would do
if i if i had a company in the new york
times
and i was losing subscribers my bottom
line was faltering i'd sit back put my
feet up light a cigar and be
like we're going down with the ship boys
it's going to be a fun ride oh my
goodness just
publish anything you want at the new
york times i'd be like they already do
ladies and gentlemen crack the cigar i'd
be like
the ship is going down i'm going down
with it i have golden parachutes
prepared severance packages for all of
you if you'd like to go or you can hang
out and we can watch and see what
happens
and then the guys who don't have golden
parachutes just stand there and play the
violin as the ship
yeah play the violin i would i would i
would rather watch the ship sink than
get taken over by
cultists i'm the kind of guy if i'm on
if i'm on my ship i got my you know my
what like 17th century frigate or
galleon or whatever
and i'm transporting my important cargo
and pirates come
i'm gonna be like scuttle the ship and
burn it to the ground before i give it
to these people
you want to steal my ship you want to
board kill my people and take over
nope we're burning it to the ground
before we let you have it so
new york times doesn't do that though
yeah i guess the question is how much is
the new york time being i mean obviously
there's some coercion there because they
published the article of their own free
will and then took it down but
they're they i mean they've always been
to the left it's not as if these are
right-wingers coming in and forcing them
to say things that would contradict
their previously held biases
that's that's the issue they that's like
the joke i was making where
in like 2030 you see the new york times
covered in vines you go in and there's
journalists like all like haggard like
zombies
because their desperation to latch on to
being left they can never give it up
that's fair so i was talking to a friend
of mine and i was explaining the left
has gone insane
and i said have you ever stopped to
consider how weird it is that barack
obama was called deporter
in chief and his vice president right
alongside with him
created the cages in home in in what
homestead florida
and then as four years later all of a
sudden he's for decriminalizing border
crossings a moratorium on deportations
how in four years did he jump so far on
that issue
the left has been radicalized and
moderates and conservatives are in a
very similar space they've been for the
past
20 30 years yeah i mean i think the
right wing has changed to some extent
but the worst thing you could commit
yourself to is being left-wing because
that's always going to change
i think unfortunately presently the
right wing has more or less become this
very loose association with people who
have vaguely
similar views about the economy and then
socially
the views are all over the board so we
don't have a very strong right wing or
conservative movement currently
but i think we need to develop something
much more robust and as i said earlier
rooted in catholicism in 2006 the right
wing was pro-war
go kill kill kill get the oil yep yeah
yeah yeah
the right has changed so much and it's
really depressing
and it's funny though because what the
right was in like 2006
2007 around that time during the bush
era was
mostly neoconservative and trump has
sort of changed that and actually
brought it back to something a little
more old-school not entirely because
he's very socially liberal
but his more like populist economic
policies and his attitudes towards
issues being based on what he thinks
are best for is best for like working
people uh
is i think like a more traditional
version of conservatism than we've had
in this country
and these these black lives matter are
neo-liberals they're not liberals
liberalism is good
in ba right balance yeah that's this
weird
aberration of liberalism is it's not
it's not that's why people started
saying classical liberalism
to protect what it means to be a
legitimate let's
what does classical liberal mean either
because like sometimes classically
liberal is made to refer specifically to
or is used to refer specifically to
enlightenment values but i think more
recently people who
would have been considered liberal 10
years ago but now are considered
moderate call themselves classically
liberal
they're wrong they don't they're up with
us okay good i'm on the same page as you
but i've noticed many people using the
phrase that way and i'm yeah i'm curious
what your thoughts are on that because
because uh and also what the proper
label is for those people if you're
talking about people who are liberal 10
years ago you're talking about social
liberals yeah like sock dams maybe so uh
no no no no no no no no not necessarily
because wouldn't you say the liberals 10
years ago probably were in favor of like
universal health yeah that was me they
were government power
yeah well obama was okay so social
liberalism
is almost identical to classical
liberalism but it leans more towards
solving social issues with government
yeah not it's not extreme it's not far
left it's center-left
so it's basically that classical
liberals are like i don't know i lean
more towards a free market solution and
social liberal is
yeah but some of these things can't be
solved by a free market and then we hold
hands and we sing songs and we
compromise
because you're like standing next to
each other what they've become
like they're not liberal at all so i've
heard a lot of people say i used to be a
liberal i guess i'm a classical
in the sense no no you're talking about
john locke you're talking about exactly
what is essentially a very
libertarian position in the u.s yes
you want to hit something oh i used to
be you're like social democrat
socially liberal i was well social
social democrat is typically a reference
to a stronger welfare state yeah it used
to be like that
but so social liberal isn't because like
oh interesting a social democrat is pr
is not a person who would necessarily
say that
you know the state needs to seize
ownership of the means of production and
return that to the people they believe
in a market economy they just want it to
be really strongly regulated and they
want for there to be a very robust
welfare state definitely if you look at
like vanderbilt and his
uh use of the railroads in the 1800s he
strangled new york city he had the
only rail line in and out of new york
and he just said one day you know what
screw you i've heard i've heard crazy
stories of modern day versions of that
with internet
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you